[Music]
getting comfortable with being
uncomfortable for a period of time
is actually a great life skill
[Applause]
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
i'm so happy for you to meet gary
thank you i'm really happy as well
before we started
so i i was telling maha all about um
how i relate to you in the way that you
used to think about school a lot
and i i really feel like the same
and i have that entrepreneurial mindset
that
that you have and i when i i always i
follow you on tech talk and instagram
when i
i watch your videos every day uh and
every time i
i hear you talk about something that i
can relate to
like i i completely relate to it and
and me and my parents always have this
debate about school and i tell them like
i want to i want to start a business i
want to get into drop shipping i want to
do this and then
mother's like no do chemistry and then
you know all of that
so it's uh so when i heard that my dad
was was working with you i was like that
i watch gavi every day
he's one of my idols like really and
then he was like
i'll try my best to get him to meet you
and when he told me that that he
organized the meeting it was
like this is like the best thing i could
ever ask for and so i want to really
thank you so much for this
amazing opportunity of course you can't
imagine how that feels to be heard
so thank you so much for those kind
words is there anything
you want to focus on on this
conversation
i mean i just i want to i want to get
your your perspective on
on on what i should do your advice on on
how i should
and how i should act because like
obviously there's the side of my parents
telling me
one thing and the side of what i really
want to do
and then there is also this like middle
place that it's like
my parents are providing me with
everything and they're really amazing
and
i love them so much and and they give me
great advice
but on this specific thing i i really
feel like i wanna
i wanna try and and explore my
my strengths and my weaknesses and learn
from my mistakes if i
if i start a business or drop shipping
or whatever it is early
and i just i can't i get that across
my parents i think a lot of times people
in life think
about or when the answer is actually and
you know i i wasn't able to convince
my parents either to not go to college
you know i didn't want to and i went for
four years
because i loved my parents so much and i
just you know
i think you know i'm sure maha can tell
you the same thing and anybody who's
lived a little bit
getting comfortable with being
uncomfortable for a period of time
is actually a great life skill and
honestly
you know no matter how much including
myself one loves entrepreneurship
the vacation that is
being young and just going to school
is you know that's what i the reason i
was able to
be okay the last four or five years
mentally was
i basically said well this will be my
last real vacation
before i go into my real life and so
you know i think what i was fortunate
enough was my parents
didn't stop me from doing
business stuff on the side
obviously i worked for my family's
liquor store business and i was doing my
sports card and
flipping and garage sailing and so you
know yeah
if you're in a position where your
parents aren't completely stopping you
from doing things on the side and saying
no you can't you
you you're forbidden you must only study
if you're lucky enough that you can do
both
i would tell you that you have plenty of
time
in front of you yeah what you want but i
do think the sooner you can start
tasting you know drop shipping
uh influencer marketing nft
cryptocurrency all this stuff looks easy
on paper
it's good in theory but then when you do
it it's much harder than people think
and i think the sooner you can
taste the ups and the downs
it's kind of like exercising you'll be
more prepared
for when you do it full-time it's like
prepping for a fight
you'll be ready for that fight so i
think you know are you are you in a
position where
you can start doing some of this stuff
on the side um i think i can what
i spoke to my dad about was doing this
in summer
um and and one of my and my dad had a
meeting with the with an american
businessman
uh and he um he's based in arizona and
he has a lot of friends and real estate
and and everything and he came to
our house a week ago and i have um plans
to go and visit them in arizona and
and expand my knowledge about because
i'm really interested in real estate as
well doing real estate in the future
so so i basically planned my whole
summer to do that
and um and what what my my dad tells me
a lot
is that he feels that i'm lazy and i
don't disagree with him
uh i can be i have the tendency to be
lazy
but i also you're lazy because you're
disinterested
exactly exactly 100 when i was
13 to 18 i was told by
many many people that i was lazy they
just happened to be people that
were at school you know yeah
and maybe my grandma sometimes around
the house
because i didn't want to hang a picture
but you know
i uh you know it makes me laugh so much
because people thought i was lazy yet
my life's destiny was to be synonymous
with work ethic
yeah like i i really feel like
if i had something interesting like when
i watch all those
videos about uh business and marketing
and real estate
i expand like three like hours like just
just watching and just listening
and it's so interesting and i'm so
captivated in the moment
but as soon as i switch back to my
chemistry class and they start talking
about
all this other stuff like in two minutes
i'm so disinterested
so uninterested in whatever they're
talking about i lived your life my
friend
i understand i i it got so bad for me
that i started bringing wine magazines
to school
and i would read them in the middle of
class
like literally i i basically realized
something
i realized that my high school was more
interested in me passing because they
were going for a blue ribbon status in
new jersey
which required everybody graduating i
realized that
i could as long as i showed up for
school
that i was going to pass and the second
i realized that i basically
read wine magazines in class or fooled
around or daydreamed or
doodled or whatever you know i
i think the key here is perspective
one you're gonna have you're not
missing out today it's nfts
tomorrow it's vr the next day it's
something that not the three of us could
even imagine
so i think you've got to make sure that
you don't have anxiety of missing out
once you have a good relationship with
that what you need to do is just focus
on learning as much as you can
around the things that you're passionate
about you know ultimately
your parents will be okay no matter what
as long as you're healthy and happy but
you might have to have a little bit of
pain in between
now and that success yeah i mean i
um what one story that about that you
that we were talking about that that
really
sort of got me really interested was um
i remember when you said that it was it
was i think around christmas time
and you were in the working in the
liquor store and you were making
crazy amounts an hour and this lady that
lived like two hours away
you had she ordered this um pink rose
bottles or something and then you had to
get in your car and drive all the way in
the snow
and then i i thought like i was
when i when i watched that video i
literally i said out loud like
this is like so genius this is so what i
want to be doing i want to
i want to have my business i want to
have i want every customer to know that
that whatever the order is going to be
there that like that
that quality like that that's what i
study and
and i'm in a better position than than
maybe you were
when you were in school next year um i
only do three subjects that
i like so i'm going to do business
economics and politics
so i i always i told my dad like that
next year i can
i can full i can get like everything
that all the grades that i would need
and everything because it would be
interesting and i told my dad like
i'm going to go to university maybe not
but it's like more of a safety net so if
so if something happens i have a plan we
have a degree to fall back on something
that
that people look for when when when
they're hiring
by the by the time you're hiring and
succeed let's say
you go through that and it's university
four years for you is that how it works
or three or yeah four years yeah
by the time you that's that'll be five
years of school it sounds like because
you have one more year is that what you
said earlier
and then university i have two more
years two more years more years i mean
that's six then you try to do your thing
let's say
it fails after two years in eight years
the amount of businesses that are going
to be hiring without university is
enormous
i would tell you to think about it
differently and perspective matters
instead of thinking about it as your
fallback plan because the reality is
if you keep networking i mean if you
just stay in touch with maha
just her just her for the next eight
years every six months
hello tex whatever she'll be more likely
to help you get a job that's meaningful
for you
than your universe i promise you getting
a job with me is more about your
relationship with maha
than some piece of paper of some school
that i've never heard of promise
yeah i think the key is perspective i
think if you think about
university as something that you want to
do
for your parents because they've done so
much for you
you'd be surprised on how it feels going
through
university i believe that if you think i
believe that you know in your heart
that it being a fallback piece of paper
is [ __ ]
but i don't believe that you think going
for four years for your parents is
[ __ ] as a matter of fact
based on the way you're talking i think
that it would make you happy to do that
for your parents
it will make me happy and i
and i know that because the thing is
that my dad he
he went through the normal process and
it was really hard for him
and and um and he had to and he had to
work
so hard and he was such a disadvantage
because of his circumstances there was
civil war and everything when he was
going up
so for him the fact that he he made
success like as um as an employee and as
like working for
for a company after so many years and
the growth of the company with
while he was with them exponentially
grew so
i am so that's why i i always completely
understand my dad
when he tells me like you have to go to
university this is the only way
uh like what else you're gonna do um
no no job is gonna look for you without
a degree and then i
i always tell my dad like that take a
quote from from elon musk
the people that i didn't go to harvard
but the people that work for me did
and then my dad was like and then always
ask me how many elon musks are there in
the world and
i told that the problem is there's a lot
more they don't they're not
elon musk but the amount of people
that are entrepreneurs that were not
built for school
that have gone on to successful but more
importantly
happy lives that have far more
college-educated
students literally almost everybody
that works for my companies the 1500
current employees and the tens of
thousands
that have worked for me in my life
literally almost
all of them outside of a couple
scrappers at wine library stock boys
have been on paper more educated than me
forget about my financial success in
comparison to the majority of them
it's the sheer happiness of living
what's in your dna
that is so important yeah i view
entrepreneurship like i view art
i really do i really do i believe that
artists who are truly artists are happy
to live
by financial humble means to be able to
draw
or to doodle or whatever they do and
if that means they'll make 60 63 000
a year scrapping by a side job and
selling a couple of
paintings that if they truly are a true
artist not one who thought they wanted
to be an artist to become
banksy or make money or be famous or be
a rock star and date models i mean truly
i am an artist and i love it i believe
they're happier than
than than a you know chemical engineer
making 800
000 a year and i think i think that's
why i associate with entrepreneurship so
much
more about the freedom of being happy
about doing your true mission
than the financial success that's
associated with it
because when i got into it it wasn't
cool like it is right now
do you understand how crazy it is for me
to have young men
like you say that i'm your idol there
was no thought
that businessmen or women were cool when
i was your age
athlete musician but never even you know
the most famous businessman
that was doing something progressive was
bill gates and his glasses were the size
of my head
you know it was the furthest it was
culture
for the progressive businessman or very
old people like a businessman on tv
would be a 70 year old man with white
hair
right you know so so you know
you know it's very fascinating how
things evolve but i would tell you
that i think because i have to run right
now i just realized i apologize but
you know i think hey let's stay in touch
b
b converted to the fact that you're
doing it for your parents
and i think you'll enjoy it a lot more
the next six years
and thank you so much just keep talking
to your father
about what you believe thank you
thank you so much history will prove you
right and the end
yeah that's cool for your side hustle
it's it's
it's ann it's and yeah i saw you
recorded this
let's let's chop some of this and put in
my content and we'll make it
exactly i was gonna send it to the team
such good stuff
cheers thank you so much thank you
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my commitment
and exploration of youtube is about to
explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you